TO SPEND TIME WITH US.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR INFINITE
INSIGHT.
THIS IS HUGE NEWS TONIGHT.
JOINING US NOW, OHIO CONGRESSMAN
JIM JORDAN.
REMEMBER JIM JORDAN AND GUYS
LIKE MATT GAETZ AND CERTAINLY
MARK MEADOWS AND JOHN RATCLIFFE,
I DON'T WANT TO MISS ANYBODY.
THEY HAVE BEHIND CLOSED DOORS,
AS CONGRESSMAN DOUG CONGRESS
REVEALS, YOU ARE ASKING THE
RIGHT QUESTIONS AT THE RIGHT
TIME.
NOW THAT WE HAVE THESE THREE OH
TWO AND ALL OF THIS CONFIRMATION
THAT YOU ARE HEARING TONIGHT, WE
SEEM TO HAVE TWO SEPARATE PATHS
THAT WE USE FOR SPYING.
AGAIN, THE 99% OF THE FBI, GREAT
PEOPLE.
THE PREMIER LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY IN THE WORLD.
ON OUR INTELLIGENCE I, THE
PREMIER INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES IN
THE WORLD.
BUT AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS, IT
SEEMS THAT BOTH WE HAD
OUTSOURCING OF TACTICS AND MEANS
OF SUPPLYING ON AMERICANS THAT
WOULD BE ILLEGAL, THEY DID IT
PURPOSELY TO CIRCUMVENT AMERICAN
LAWS AND ON HAD A SIGH, WE HAVE
THE DIRTY DOSSIER.
THEN WE HAVE A GUY THAT'S FIRED
FOR LYING AND LEAKING AND HE'S
GOT A CONDUIT AND THE CONDUIT IS
BRUCE OHR WHOSE WIFE, BY THE
WAY, HOW TO BUILD THE DIRTY
RUSSIAN DOSSIER FOR
HILLARY CLINTON AND FUSION GPS.
IT AS YOU READ THIS, FILL IN THE
BLANKS SO THE AUDIENCE HERE CAN
UNDERSTAND THIS COMPLETELY.
>> THAT LAST POINT I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT.
WHY DO YOU TERMINATE YOUR DIRECT
RELATIONSHIP WITH
CHRISTOPHER STEELE AND THEN
ENCOURAGE A TOP JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL TO KEEP
MEETING WITH HIM AND THEN COMING
IN BRIEFING KNEW ABOUT EACH OF
THOSE MEETINGS INTO THAT
CONVERSATION?
IT SEEMS LIKE YOU ARE TRYING TO
HIDE SOMETHING OR CAMOUFLAGE
SOMETHING WHEN YOU DO THAT.
WHAT'S I CAN, WHY DO YOU DO
THROUGH TWOS?
BECAUSE YOU ARE OUT TO GET
SOMETHING OR SOMEONE.
WHO ARE THEY ARE TO GET?
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES FOR A LOOK AT THE
12 302'S AND NOTICED THE DAY.
THERE ARE THREE VERSES P.A.
THERE IS A BIRTHRIGHT AFTER THE
ELECTION, THE BIRTH RIGHT AFTER
THE INAUGURATION, AND THEN THE
EIGHT ONES MAY RIGHT AFTER THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S NAMES.
SO THIS ALL JUST SHOWS THEY ARE
OUT TO GO AFTER THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES AND NEVER
FORGET, THE GUY WHO IS LEADING
THE INVESTIGATION SAID CLINTON
SHOULD LEAVE IT A HUNDRED
MILLION TO ZERO.
THEY STOP SEAN.
WE GOT A INSURANCE POLICY.